kids weren't exactly a priority for the
40 year old virgin
the steve carrell classic is turning 15
and we're celebrating with some fun
behind the scenes secrets
i'm sure it'll look a lot worse than it
actually is i'm really not worried i
don't think it's going to hurt
yeah steve underestimated the pain that
was coming his way
no special effects and the movie's most
memorable scene was actually steve's
idea
it wouldn't be as funny if you faked it
i personally pitch the whole waxing idea
i know it was kind of a stupid stupid
idea
behind the scenes corralplay.com even
though multiple takes
weren't going to be an option the crew
set up five cameras so they'd be sure to
get the shot
i can now empathize with every woman
who's ever had their
legs waxed or done a bikini wax
i i salute you my comrades nothing but
respect
you got to respect the guy who's willing
to wax himself for the art
as for this iconic line no kelly
clarkson
the line was ad-libbed and kelly had no
idea it existed until the trailer came
out i was kind of like is that a
compliment i'm not sure
you want to clear the air well i did
with her it's a complete compliment
steve says it took more than two months
to get his chest hair back you know what
guys
this is not a good look for me
essentially i have a
face carved into my chest hair and my
wife was a bit horrified
by the whole experience you look like a
man-o-lantern
steve also dropped 30 pounds to play
andy but the studio thought paul rudd
gained too much weight for his role so
production was shut down for two days so
he could fast
you can see paul looks a little heavier
in the speed dating scene
than in the rest of the film amy what
are you doing here
the movie is also full of firsts it
marked mindy kaling's first on-screen
role
judd apatow's directorial debut and
steve's first time as a leading man
i love it i love watching me
i wish there was more me in the movie
i'm sure that picture will kind of
follow me
until the end of time
you